if you want investors to put money into
your business you have to go to them
with more than just a plan go to them
with some traction go to them with some
momentum go to them with some customers
if you can do that you dramatically
increase your chances of getting the
money you need to grow this business hi
I'm Evan Carmichael and I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
so today mates in a question from one of
my YouTube viewers his name is Shalon
from the Netherlands thank you for
watching he said I built the new social
media platform how can I reach you big
investors with millions of dollars to
look at my plan and maybe invest in it
so thanks for the questions you're on
you have to go with more than just a
plan for a social media platform when I
was in the venture capital business my
role was bringing in new deals and
looking at thousands of business plants
and the ones that got turned away were
always the ones who just had an idea
they had no traction they had no track
record they had barely a team they had
no customers no revenue that's not an
easy business to raise money for you
have to have something to stand up from
the crowd the problem is everybody with
an idea just goes out and pitches
investors to find the list of venture
capital investors is not hard to do to
get them to actually put money your
business is hard and so you want to go
to them showing how you're different
than the other 99% of the companies that
are pitching to them you're more than
just an idea so you build a team you
build an advisory board you actually
start building something building your
product building your service out you
start getting some traction with the
media you start getting some partners
all those out as possible without
getting funding you may not make huge
head waves but that's okay you don't
need to go out and land huge
multi-million dollar deals just show me
that you can get one customer get one
paying customer for what you do and
already you set yourself apart from
everybody else most of the people who
are pitching these venture capitalists
otherwise you're gonna spend your time
making this business plan pitching
investors and you're gonna get shot down
every time you go out raising money is
almost a full-time business in itself
and it's going to distract you from
being able to build the business on your
own the best way to do it is to
bootstrap it from the start put your
hard earned time into it work the late
hours do whatever you can to convince
people to help you out
you got a bootstrap this thing up start
building momentum and traction into this
business try to get at least a couple
customers to pay you and show that what
you have works and then go to investors
to get money to expand this business
embarrassments don't don't expect you to
have everything all planned out but you
have to have something more than just a
plan on paper otherwise they're gonna
say no I hope that helps maybe some
tough love for you there but I want to
make sure that you get the best chance
that you have like getting the money
that you're looking for for those of you
watching if you liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below makes you want
to do more for you more videos and if
you have a question about this video or
about raising capital or about anything
else with your business I'd love to try
to answer it for you if you want to
leave it in the comment section below
so thank you and I'll see you on the
next episode
you